sedrati ou de g eh bien écoutez je me
suis jamais posé la question je pense
plutôt droitier mais quand tu sais
droitière je m'adresse au spectacle
voilà c'est fait manoir tiendra donc tu
penses que tu es droitier je suis
inquiet c'est belge est une autre bonne
nouvelle pour toi c'est pas possible si
c'est comme pour les gens qui ont les
yeux clairs en france avoir surprise
c'est une surprise
qu'est ce qui va venir maintenant quatre
ans a bâti non regarde ton petit
téléviseur
elle va voir
ils sont célèbres adulé de john mcenroe
à léonard de vinci ou paul mccartney en
passant par des tôles charlie chaplin ou
george bush mais ne cédez pas à la
tentation de les envier car ils sont
avant tous gauchers conséquence leur vie
est un perpétuel sursis c'est ce qu'ont
démontré deux études américaines dont la
plus récente est paru dans la sérieuse
revue de new england journal of medecine
les gauchers vivent moins longtemps pied
droit tu y es 9 ans - pour les hommes à
droite six ans de moins pour les femmes
les causes en serait d'abord
physiologique il semblerait que le
gaucher soit plus vulnérables en
particulier à certaines maladies
elle indique qu on appelle des maladies
auto immunes ce qui ferait penser donc
le système immunitaire et doit préparer
à réagir mais les vraies raisons de
cette différence ont tout simplement
liés à l'environnement
tout est conçu pour les droitiers les
poignées de portes les ciseaux les
couteaux bref la vie du gaucher est un
combat tout instant et ce dès le plus
jeune âge
au départ ça pose des premières
écritures parce que dès qu'on écrit à la
plume forcément passe la main sur ce
qu'on vient d'écrire et ça fait des
cahiers qui sont toujours mal tenu et on
avait une réputation de quelqu'un qui
sait pour qui c'est mal écrire ou mal
présenté les choses bien souvent m'a pas
pris pour un handicapé mais pas loin
quand même les gauchers aurait 25 % de
plus d'accidents du travail est six fois
plus d'accidents de voiture des
conclusions qui pourrait faire réfléchir
les sociétés d'assurance vie
certaines demandent déjà aux
contractants s'ils sont obèses s'ils
fument ou s'ils boivent et les surtaxes
si ces éléments s'additionnent ce
critère pour être retenu par les
assureurs s'il est vrai que les
statistiques prouvent que les droitiers
et les gauchers ont une espérance de vie
plus importante là effectivement ça
pourrait peut-être pris en compte
ils représentent 10% de la population
mondiale on a tout dit sur leur compte
d'après la rumeur il serait plus souvent
efféminé voir homosexuels plus gauche
tout simplement
maintenant on leur reproche d'être moins
résistants honnêtement ça m'impressionne
pas du tout parce que je préfère avoir
une vie bien remplie plus courte qu'une
vie plus longue et ennuyeuse
ils sont entrés dans l'histoire et pas
toujours du pied gauche mais à quel âge
compte il en sortir les droitiers
plus longtemps que les gauchers s de
l'info s de l'intox
jean pierre foucault à l'oreille alors
elle après celle à la taxe
c'est tout est joué ma fille passer de
la france info pourquoi pourquoi bon les
bastons et droitier du même droit que
trop de grosses chutes fait quoi tu
prends le droit de l'enfance leur fou ma
foi qui fait quoi et ménage ou un
endroit qui est mon droit
c'est fou et bien comme ton modèle et
toi c'est de l'info alors jean pierre
foucault m'a dit que c'est de l'intox
lui à moi je veux dire un faux en tous
les cas si c'est de l'info pour toi
c'est génial parce que tu fais les yeux
clairs sorti de l'auberge
tu as les yeux clairs oui j'ai droitier
tu vas nous faire un centenaire là on
écoute l'expert philippe guérin
et oui mon sosie et moi même sommes
peut-être perdant au jeu ce soir mais
gagnant sur un autre tableau puisque
nous sommes tous les deux est droitier
et nous avons les yeux clairs c'était de
l'info il pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu